i saw a video on on instagram where
these dudes were driving down the
freeway
and you were running doing road work
down the freeway and they were filming
you
and uh how much did you run for that
fight i first did i did um
i did a mile and a half my first run in
there did a mile and a half
and then um my last running date i did
six miles
six holy [ __ ] oh that's legit
how old are you now 51 52 64 years old
and got back in shape and running six
miles yeah oh absolutely you're moving
but i ran the six but then i walked to
three so that was like nine and a half
on the road work i did
holy [ __ ] and he looked amazing in his
last fight against roy jones
i'm gonna go all out in this fight i
mean it's gonna work totally
the whole session just do it all how did
you feel in there did you feel good
i feel better than i anticipated yeah i
thought i would be a little nervous
than i was and i was really relaxed
how did you feel though you felt you
felt good during the fight you felt like
i felt like wow i could do some more i
could
have much more companies i could do this
i could do that
and i said wow this is interesting and i
said well i want to do it again
i want to do what somebody i could do go
really i love it all out on
yeah yeah it made me it made me
interested in wanting to do it again
yeah roy said royce said your [ __ ]
power is still unbelievable
yeah you got to see him in the gym but i
wanted to go to the distance
i didn't want to knock nobody out and
all that that's what people expect i
wanted to go to distance
and stuff you got to see him in the gym
man you being there
you'll be banging stuff up man you're
looking good thank you
i'm happy for you yeah i was worried
about you know they're going into that
thing so
i'm happy for you if there's anything
that i can do if there's anything in the
world
if there's anything i can do i can fight
yeah
first of all let me say this so somebody
asked me
i told them i didn't like it and then
somebody asked me publicly
about it at a press conference and i
said yeah i don't like it
i i you know there's mike tyson is super
famous there's
lots of other ways for him to make money
i don't want to see him get punched in
the head
so he feels sorry for me i can make
money he gives me a job or what's that
thing shark week shark week
so he really likes me he really cares
about me
oh [ __ ] dana really cares oh god he
really cares about my well-being
he's gonna leave me i'd rather fight a
lot now i gotta think about a shark
oh he really cares about me this is true
this is exactly what happened so
i called him and said don't don't
[ __ ] do this man don't do this
it's whatever i said listen i i got you
i got you a tv show i got him shark week
thank you feed him to this show shark
week
so he had to go down and swim with these
sharks and he was i
i heard the day that he actually went in
and swim he was super pissed off and
the whole crew was scared that day
because because mike didn't want to get
in the water with the sharks
and then they turned the boat off and
they both started rocking after the pool
they're gonna get both stickers and i
gotta go
so then somebody asked me at a press
conference about it and i said listen i
don't like it
i i don't want him to do it and this and
that so then he called me he's like
he's like listen man you and me are
friends we've been friends for a long
time
i'm a grown ass man if i want to [ __ ]
fight i'm gonna fight don't don't be
[ __ ]
negative about my fight you know and i
said you know what you're right
you won't hear you won't hear a [ __ ]
peep out of me again but it's all good
for karen though like what did you think
when you when i watched the fight
yeah i mean when i watched the fight i
thought he looked really [ __ ] good no
but listen no forget that though
just listen to this world listen to this
world i'm following my again 54.
they want to give me a hundred million
dollars of faith in it and you think i'm
going to say no
that's more than i got fighting them for
championships
no you know come on please i'd love to
fight you i'd love to
it's true though it's true and he loved
to he believes well listen
i love the guy i just i just you know i
love the guy
i i i just have this thing man when we
when you get to a certain age
it's just tough to perform at a level
that you did when you were younger and
and there's no reason he's he can make
money anywhere he can make money doing
anything
but he's not wrong i will admit you know
when you get offered that kind of money
it's hard to [ __ ] turn it down
to do something you've been good at your
entire life your whole life yeah yeah
yeah because i never thought about doing
all these years i could have done this
stuff
but then somebody said i said i can get
a charity i can make this bigger than
what it really was
and that's really why i wanted to do it
yeah michael's had a good bank you care
about me so you put me on [ __ ] shark
weed yeah
yeah you see me get a shark i'm throwing
it
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you